perhaps this is a good place to also
mention
a little bit of a fun
Little controversy that evolved over
Twitter so I posted a reading list
quickly before heading off to a New
Year's party of books that I hope to
read in 2023 and these are based on
books that I asked people to vote on and
these are the ones many of the ones they
selected and they happen to be many of
the books I've read many times
throughout my life and really enjoyed
and they were like old friends that I
love visiting and revisiting and every
time I read them I get something new and
they they're just
read different throughout life
you know the way in my teens when I read
The Stranger by Camus was very different
than it was in my 20s and different in
my 30s I'll say my favorite book Now by
kamu is probably the plague and all of
that has evolved with Dostoyevsky I read
the idiot several times I read Brothers
karmazov both in English and Russian
Notes from Underground I mean I love
Dostoyevsky and a lot of these books are
just
yes they are Classics but they're also
deeply profound and they move me on a
intellectual level but also just as a
human being they're like travel
companions they're like old friends
uh old to dead friends
so yeah so I was wanted to celebrate my
love for books and it was very strange
to me that
um and if I'm just being honest for a
second is kind of painful that
um some prominent figures uh that I
respect
were kind of cruel about the list and
they they responded they mocked it and
all that kind of stuff
and basically taking the worst possible
interpretation
and
I have to be honest and say it was um
it wasn't fun because uh
it was just
it was just a silly kid me
kind of in a joyful New Year's mood
sharing with the world books I love
and
I think what was happening and this
seems to be happening a bit more
is there's a bunch of people that are
just almost waiting or hoping that I
fail or maybe that
I'm some kind of bad human being and
they they're looking they're trying to
discover things about me
that reveal that I'm a bad human being
and maybe somehow
um
this reading list reveals that I don't
know uh
I don't know
so one criticism
was that everybody read these books in
school and they're basic
I think my response to that criticism is
no first of all most people have not
read them in school maybe they're very
Cliff Notes and they're not basic
they're deeply profound some of the
greatest words ever written
but also
I don't think I've ever gotten
a lot from books I was forced to read in
school when I had to read them for like
an assignment some of these books I
think I've read in school but most of
them not but it's only when I read them
outside of school on my own volition
that I really gained a lot from it and
especially throughout my life regular
times as a teenager as a 20 in my 20s
and in my 30s
so no these books are profound and
deserve returning to and like I said
there are old friends that give me a lot
of meaning every time I return to
revisit the ideas and give me a new
perspective on life
another criticism was very kind of
nitpicky and the list was put together
really quickly and the goal I like
setting tough goals the goal is to read
a book a week and you know on one week I
had uh a little prince
followed by brothers karamazov and
people criticized uh that how can you
possibly read Brothers karamazov in one
week maybe I won't maybe I'll fail
miserably uh but I love trying and but
that's not actually was that wasn't
actually the goal I should have said I
intend to finish reading it by the end
of that week so you start earlier
because Little Prince uh takes you know
an hour or two to read and then Brothers
karamazov
um I could have the two weeks it should
take about 30 40 50 hours to read it
that said friends
I've read it already in English and in
Russian I'm interviewing uh the the
world famous I would say amazing
translators of Brothers karamazov of of
uh Dostoevsky of Tolstoy Richard pavirin
and Larissa volkowski
uh probably across multiple days so this
book means a lot to me I'm not uh
somebody's just kind of rolling in what
are the cool kids reading these days
these books have been lifelong
companions to me and the fact that
people just want to stomp on that and
a large number of people did people have
respect
yeah I'll be lying if I said it wasn't
it didn't suck a bit
anyway the
the love for reading
um
uh persists I have to say after that I
was very hesitant to even make this
particular video on Orwell on 1984.
and I'm not sure I want to be public
with my reading after this and I know a
lot of people will say no there's uh
like we're here with you where they're
very supportive and I love you I mean I
meet so many incredible people but the
reality just does suck to be vulnerable
and share something with the world and
uh receive that kind of uh that kind of
mockery at scale so
uh I will definitely I can I will not be
affected or broken by any of that kind
of stuff for something that's actually
meaningful like the conversations that
some of the very difficult conversations
I'm going to do but a silly side hobby
thing of reading that I do throughout my
life
uh for that to be a source of mockery
I'm just going to do that privately so
I'm a little torn on that and I'll I'll
try to figure out a way
um also I should say that that list like
a lot of things is kind of aspirational
because if I take a job at a time at a
tech company
or if I start a tech company or if I
have to travel across
um
I have to travel for extremely difficult
conversations and really have to prepare
for them all that kind of stuff I think
that's going to affect my ability to
both read and enjoy reading which I
think is a prerequisite for this kind of
reading but in general what I do is I
read about one hour a day of Kindle so
on on the sort of in my eyes physical
device
and uh depending on the workout I do and
the chores I have it's going to be about
two hours of audiobook so most of the
things I do during chores is audiobooks
and when I run and I usually run about
10 to 15 miles so you're talking about
because I often run over two hours it's
like a slow pace like when the days are
not insane it gives me a chance to think
it gives me a chance to listen to
audiobooks so I love that process it's
the Escape for the world a chance for me
to collect my thoughts and uh yeah it's
again a source of happiness and joy and
I wanted to share that and um
do I think you can get quite a lot of
reading done through that process
um especially if it's book you've read
before it is very challenging to do this
kind of takeaway video or to concretize
your thoughts down on paper especially
when you have to present them in this
kind of way I'm not sure I'm going to do
that much because it's an extra bit of
effort but it's also a chance to share
that Joy with the world so uh to find
cool people that also enjoy it so it's a
trade-off anyway I you know it's just a
temporary thing but it um
it did suck for for a short amount of
time for a few hours for for a couple
days but in general you know I'll
persist with my level of reading but I
might not talk about it publicly as much
but again let me sort of emphasize
that this kind of response and mockery
will not affect anything of importance
that I do
like I I always
I try to read comments I try to see
criticism I really value especially High
effort criticism I try to grow and
constantly try to improve
but that's for things that that I take
very seriously like the the the podcast
conversations that I do but for silly
things
like book lists
Spotify music playlists the food I like
to eat
I don't know
what else
anything any fun like uh side thing it's
not that it's not that important if
um if if it's something that others
don't enjoy then whatever uh I'll enjoy
them probably with my friends locally
here or the people I meet so anyway I
love reading I love reading Classics I
love returning to old friends and uh in
in book form and making new ones there's
a bunch of Science Fiction that I
embarrassingly have not read
and would love to because those worlds
are so meaningful to so many of the
people I'm friends with that I can't
wait to visit those worlds and sort of
make new friends in the form of books so
definitely the love for books the love
for reading persists and if you share in
that love that's beautiful so uh thank
you for joining me on this journey thank
you for watching this uh silly little
video and I hope to see you next time
love you all